hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
distinctions that st. Augustine of Hippo
makes in book one of on free choice of
the will is that between two
fundamentally different kinds of law one
of which we very easily recognize
because we're governed by it and we
think of ourselves as operating within
its confines and that is what he would
call temporal law if we recognize some
Universal standards of morality that we
think don't differ from place to place
and time to time then we also recognize
what he calls the eternal law and in
Augustine's work the eternal law has a
priority over the temporal law so this
is a very important distinction he tells
us that the eternal law is the what he
calls the law of reason and it cannot
change the temporal law by by contrast
can in fact change and will vary from
place to place and situation to
situation as the matter of fact it
always didn't even brings up cases where
the the temporal law must change to
adapt to new circumstances and he
is that here we go this is in section 15
will not any man intelligent man regard
that law as unchangeable and eternal
which is termed the law of reason we
must always obey it he says it is the
law through which wicked people deserve
an unhappy and good people a happy life
and through the which the law we have
said should be called temporal is
rightly decreed and rightly changed so
there is a dependency of the temporal
law upon the eternal law the eternal law
provides us with the criteria by which
the temporal law should be made and the
temporal law should be modified so he
tells us a little bit later that what is
just and what is lawful in the temporal
law actually derives from the eternal
law and he doesn't clarify it much more
at that point but he also says something
else that's very interesting a little
bit earlier in the work he says that a
law which is not just does not appear to
actually be a law at all there is
something of the very nature of law that
requires that it be just so there could
be laws that are as we say on the books
or you know laws in the sense of orders
from authorities that are not actually
law they're not actually binding because
they're not just when they are in
conflict with the eternal law when they
command us to do things that we know are
wrong or when they forbid us to do
things that we know we ought to do then
we've got a serious problem there and so
Augustine is articulating that what does
he mean by the the temporal law now he's
not giving you a whole treatise on law
here but he does have a couple very
interesting examples of what its scope
would be and how it might be changed so
it's well worth looking and at those
let's take a look at three particular
discussions that he has so in section 12
of this this work he tells us that
the temporal law may in fact allow its
subjects to to engage in killing to
prevent some other types of harms so for
example this is actually in 11 and then
in 212 he says the law you know is the
law just which authorizes a traveler to
kill a robber and self-protection or any
man or woman to kill an assailant if
possible before the violence has been
carried out what about laws that order a
soldier to kill the enemy if they refuse
they're punished by military authorities
can we call these laws unjust or no laws
at all and his a student of odious says
I see pretty well that a law which gives
its subjects permission to commit lesser
crimes in order to prevent greater ones
has a good defense against an accusation
of this kind it is a much lesser evil
for the assassin than for the man who
defends his own life to be killed so
we're saying that because somebody is
engaging in aggression or planning
aggression it's unfortunate that
somebody is killed but better that that
person is killed the guilty rather than
the innocent or in the case of the
soldier he says here we go when a
soldier kills the enemy he is enforcing
the law and so has no difficulty in
carrying out his duty without passion
the law itself which is issued to
protect a subject cannot be convicted of
passion if its author issued it in
obedience to God's will that is to
fulfill eternal justice he may have done
so without any passion of all even if he
issued it out of passion it does not
follow that the law need be carried out
with passion because a good law can be
issued by a man who is not good so you
know this this is an interesting
discussion here this always comes up by
the way when people talk about you know
the Ten Commandments and thou shalt not
kill was in one way in which that gets
interpreted thou shalt not commit murder
and so some forms of killing for example
self-defense might although there's
still not good in some respect they're
not as bad
as you know like going around and just
killing somebody and so the temporal law
could make these sorts of distinctions
and that could be in accordance with
eternal law he also talks a little bit
later on another great example this is
in section 14 about governments because
governments are structured by law as
well
he said let's look at the law which is
put forth in writing is is it for the
good of people living in this present
life the answer is yes it's to help us
out it's allow us to live together so he
says do these peoples and States belong
to the class of things which cannot
perish or change
are they altogether everlasting or are
they subject to time and change and his
student says well clearly they're
subject to time and change so here's
where we get to the crux if a people is
well disciplined and observant of social
good and such that every individual puts
public before private interest is not
this people rightly granted by law
authority to elect its own officials to
govern its Fairs that has affairs of the
state we're talking about representative
government representative government in
order to be for the common good actually
requires that the people who are doing
the voting think about the common good
not just their own interests not just
their own prejudices not just their own
desires but that of the entire society
and sometimes be willing to sacrifice
their own interest for the betterment of
the totality if that's not the case then
according to Augustine maybe that people
doesn't actually deserve to rule itself
so he goes on and he says if the people
deteriorates and prefers private to
public interest and sells its vote for
bribes and is corrupted by ambitious
politicians and puts into power
criminals with no sense of honor would
not any honest man a sufficient
influences left be justified in
depriving this people of self-government
and putting them under the authority of
a few honest people or even of one and
Amodeo says yes they would be so you
know that would be another configuration
of
parole law if the people can't govern
itself and it's gonna screw it up and
inevitably maybe it's better to have a
monarchy maybe it's better to have a you
know triumvirate or something like that
right
didn't we actually work out that well
for the Romans and Augustine knows that
now another thing that he discussed is
much later on and this is towards the
end of the work he's talking about the
good of the you know that we call
temporal so wealth and bodily things and
freedom and you know honors in the state
and all these sorts of things he says
how the law signs to each person their
share would be a long and difficult
matter to explain one plainly not
necessary for our purpose we need only
notice that the power of this law to
enforce itself does not extend further
than to take away and confiscate as a
punishment those things or a part of
them it brings pressure to bear through
fear and to gain an end turns and twist
the souls of the unhappy people for
whose government it is fitted they can
be you know kept in in line so you know
the the government allows sort of a
distribution of goods and it also can
take away those things and that's what
the temporal law one of its functions is
in fact what about the eternal law what
is Augustine tell us about it besides
the fact that there is an eternal law
and that the temporal law should be
looking to the eternal law in and being
structured and being changed so one
thing it right off the bat is he tells
us and this is in the same section that
the eternal law tells us human beings to
prefer eternal goods to temporal ones so
we should be less concerned about making
money or our financial status or bodily
health or you know our social status or
all of our you know relations or where
we live or go on and on and on and on
right what school we get to go to not
that those aren't good things or you
know or important things we should be
less concerned about those than we are
about eternal Goods so what are eternal
Goods possession of the virtues justice
fortitude temperance wisdom right or
prudence we ought to value that we ought
to value having a good will we ought to
value the eternal law itself above all
of these other things which means that
it doesn't say that we can't have these
other things but when push comes to
shove we should give eternal law the
preference eternal law is saying eternal
law has to be first another thing he
tells us is that everything should have
its due order and the way that this is
being translated is actually expressing
a kind of adverb or do not assume I
ordered to the greatest degree or most
ordered or most well ordered right and
that should extend to ourselves we
should actually have our rational part
running the show and not just our base
desires or you know the lusts of the
body or whatever it it's going to be and
we should also be extending that into
our fabrics of relationships within a
society including the temporal law
finally he tells us another thing about
the structure of the eternal law how it
in fact you could say
structures the the universe itself ah
here we go
hey this is in section 30 he says the
eternal law has settled this with
unchangeable firmness it is settled that
merit lies in the will whether we
deserve good things are not lies in our
Faculty of will and reward and
punishment lie in happiness and misery
so we can understand the eternal law not
just as like a set of norms where you're
like you know you should do this and you
know don't do this and then it sort of
comes down and imposes itself on our
norms it's the very fabric of the the
universe itself including how it is
in our human nature the will works and
we can either reject the eternal wall
and say I'm gonna you know try to see if
I can do things differently I'm sure
that I can have all the temporal goods
and also satisfy the eternal law because
I'm an exception to the rule we can do
that if we want to but we can't avoid
suffering the consequences of doing that
so this is a very important distinction
in Augustine's work and hopefully now
it's a little bit more clear what the
difference between these two sorts of
laws actually resides
you